Chad good to see your face again um too
uh okay let me um let me introduce if
you're here um you have uh you found
some interesting conversation and uh the
reason I have chat on is because he has
a lot of credentials I'm going to list
his number one credential for me uh up
front which is if you followed my
Instagram or my my
work um his book asked powerful
questions uh that he co-authored with
Will wise do you have it hey there it is
asked powerful questions I I tell people
to read it and I I think um they're
going to be like wait a minute did Cole
consult on this book and it's the
opposite it's the book like just
springboarded me into a lot of my work
when I was my emotional intelligence was
at its lowest and I was pointed in the
direction of Cole you have to work on
this I read a lot of stuff that had a
lot of high futin like Concepts and it
was clever and then I got to ask
powerful questions and I was like oh my
God there's a picture of a person and
then an exercise where I have to think
about things I would ask them this is
what I needed and so it's very practical
um but aside from that um Chad uh you're
you're the co-founder and CEO but it's
Chief experience officer according to
the website is that right yeah Chief
experience offer at we and me um they
help um make connection easy for
organizations and teams he's been a
tedex speaker um he's worked with
companies like JetBlue Starbucks Johnson
to Johnson Penn State Notre Dame you can
go through you see all the logos on his
website you just keep scrolling and I'm
sure they're not all on there you had to
had to limit put make my mom proud yeah
yeah your mom is very proud of all the
logos on your
website um he uh yeah you've got the um
the connection cards that teams use um
the name tags that are new right where
I've yeah I got one somewhere where is
it
yeah it's like wouldn't it name tags
that I'm just not convinced that your
name Cole or Chad is like the best
possible point of entry to a meaningful
conversation and so that uh yeah name
tags are just like put connection before
content that's beautiful I still I keep
saying I'm going to buy those and use
them for our next get together and I
haven't done it yet I would also say
that the the hand to screen is your move
that's your video move isn't it I feel
like you coined it I my buddy works in
uh Tri trks for the government and I
think you need to submit a trademark
like boom that's the that's the Chad
little field you know why I have not
used a single PowerPoint presentation in
the last 10 years and I don't intend to
use them in the next 10 and so for me
it's like if we're virtual if we're
remote this is my way of saying like hey
like come here like we're like here
right just like I want to pull them pull
you into okay anyway this intro is great
this enery is going to be amazing yeah
yeah there is going to rabit we're going
to Rabbit TR we're going to see where it
goes um one of your phrases that I like
is UN people are full of a what is it a
wealth of ungoogleable
experience yeah so everybody's carrying
a lifetime of ungoogleable experience
sitting on the eight pound block on the
top of their head top oh I didn't I had
not heard the second half of that yeah I
I say that to people and it always kind
of turns their brain on they're like oh
yeah cuz you can Google everything but I
can't I can't Google Your Story So to
that um we we've heard your credentials
I would love hear um or allow people to
hear some of your story your work
centers around connection and um you've
thought a lot about it you've invested a
lot in it you've given a lot of time and
energy to it um how did that become like
so important to you because I think
people are wrestling with I I think they
want to make moves in that direction to
get better at connecting with people and
um I think everybody knows like what you
eat's important to you like exercise or
like mental health but connect you've
decided connection is very important to
the world how did it become so important
to
you uh two Pathways one was like super
emotional and relatively
unrationed so the the emotional pathway
I saw the movie Patch Adams with Robin
Williams like at this point it's like in
you could find it on a scroll somewhere
it was made in like 1995 or something
but in the movie Robin Williams um
becomes a doctor to promote the quality
of life and he just has this amazing
ability of empathizing and really seeing
patients and interacting with them so
there there's one scene in the movie
where he walks into a terminally ill
patient's room the best smartest
clinicians and doctors could not get
this guy to eat a nurse would walk into
the room he'd throw a bed pan at him
this guy was just like get out of here
like hardest walls to connect to and
Patch walked into the room stared him
dead in the eye and he looks at this
terminally ill patient and
goes kick the
bucket push the daisies and he just
starts rattling off idioms uh about
death and then eventually after like the
fifth one the guy softens and then
throws one back and it's like you would
never find that strategy to build a
relationship of trust with a patient you
would never find that in medical
textbook but what the strategy was was
in my opinion the deepest possible level
of empathy was it was the ability to
make a connection with a stranger in
like the hardest Stranger in that moment
in about 12 seconds and so I saw that
movie and I was like uh you know the
whole movie is lovely and so I had my
whole life plan figured out I was going
to be a doctor throw on a um clown nose
promote the quality of life over
quantity using humor and connection do
it's like then I took a chemistry class
in college and that all fell through
like no way I'm going to school for 10
years to hold a scalp B and so here
comes the science entry point into uh
connection and and conversation which
is actually wait I still want to be
Patch Adams I just don't want to go to
school for 10 years to hold a scalpel is
this true can you actually heal people
through connection can you actually uh
even make a connection in 12 seconds and
so I went down this like super nerd
rabbit hole into psychology and
interpersonal psychology um and spoiler
alert
yes uh what I learned is like yeah you
connection has a really profound uh
influence on the quality of our life and
also the content of our life like what
happens what we choose to do um what
you're going to do next year
is actually quite dependent on the
connections you make this year um and I
think my passion is kind of shifted to
building relationship with trust to now
realizing that um and we didn't write
about this and and ask powerful
questions all that much because it was
focused on building a relationship of
trust with that ungoogleable lifetime of
experience but I've now realized that
questions are also an edit button that
changes what happens next literally in
the moment right I'm gonna stop talking
in a minute Cole and you're gonna maybe
toss out some question or response and
it will literally change the words that
exit my mouth and that's super
interesting to me um and then on a
grander scale if I ask
somebody a bigger question like what's
something you'd like to do more
of when I answered that question two
years ago just like small talk chitchat
with somebody what's something I like do
more of scuba diving I haven't gone in
four years I've got little kids blah
blah blah blah eight months after a
mentor asked me that question I was
underwater scuba diving and I came up
from being underwater like holy smokes I
would not actually be here if that
person didn't just toss me that question
very
nonchalantly with no idea of how it
would actually influence my material
reality moving forward so questions I
don't even know my story I'm pass about
now questions are an edit
button for or what happens
next both immediately and in the long
term
wow yeah I mean that's a that's a that's
a pretty
like almost existential way to think
about questions it reminds me of my um
my wife liked those books when she was a
kid where um you would get to like a
certain page and it would be like if you
want Susie to walk through the door go
to page 27 if you don't your own
adventure I think Bear Grills did a
version of that on Netflix where you
could like decide whether he'd the
alligator or not and you could click it
I don't know if you saw that my kids
loved it I it didn't last for long I
don't like the technology but that um I
what I really like about that thing is
um it brings the uh I think a lot of
people feel powerless to conversations
feel like they have just sort of
strapped themselves into a a river boat
and they're going down the Rapids and
whatever the Rapids whatever happens
happens and they're kind of stuck and
that questions are the ability to kind
of like get some ores like I mean it's
still not completely in your control but
the ability to navigate it um it can
create a more beautiful future and a
future that is more aligned with maybe I
don't know I guess however you think
about it what you were made for what you
feel called to next um so can I can I
add something the the metaphor of going
down the river and like the the question
is the paddle let's move into a kayak
where you have two paddles right I think
one paddle is questions and that is
absolutely an edit button and then I've
also become really clear that the way
that we listen actually has the power to
change what people
say more yesterday for example I led two
workshops they were identical workshops
I had the identical outline which for me
outline is like a little bit of a a
loose flow one group super disengaged
not interested in being there and
totally preoccupied with their own
stress and Chaos that was going on uh in
their in their life the other group
totally leaned in pumped to be there
super excited and guess which Workshop
was better not because totally of that
but the things that actually I said the
way that I led was way better in round
two because the way that they listened
changed what I said I could see that
they were wanting more and so this is
conversationally right you're like I can
see your brain is on fire right now you
have a million neurons like you're
listening to what I'm throwing out and
it's editing the words that are coming
out of my mouth um and that's really
powerful because if I see you're in a
rush or I see you're like totally
preoccupied with yourself and you're
like adjusting you're like oh you're
more focused on you than the other
person I'm G to take what I say and
short yeah yeah so I can actually draw
more from
People based on how I listen and when
you say listen you're not talking about
um you're talking about um an invisible
thing but there there are physical signs
like you you could tell they were paying
attention because they were leaned
forward Their Eyes Are Open they look
engaged um and more than that that that
is what people call active listening and
that's like level one like sure don't be
looking at your cell phone while
someone's talking level like 2 3 4 five
and
six fine uh level two three four five
and six is is actually in much more the
the choice and the mindset of present so
I don't know um I stumbl across David
Brooks's book how to know a person
recently and lovely book The One concept
that i' pick out that I think is just
like the absolute golden gem to to have
in mind entering a conversation is this
concept that he talks about of an
Illuminating gaze so what if I looked at
you and I wasn't just like oh you have a
lifetime of ungoogleable experience but
what if I looked at you and I was like
oh my gosh like I've got all these like
challenges problems and you probably
have some like perspective that might
actually help with that and and to look
at you as like the smartest most
incredible individual that has something
to offer the world not just me it's a
very selfish perspective but has
something to offer and that Illuminating
gaze where you're actually lighting
somebody up as opposed to what I
typically do is
scan judgment filter everything they say
through whatever judgment I've thrown
out at them it's God it's so easy to do
it's so I so I think people will push
back sometimes when they get here where
they hear all this intentionality around
connection and conversation and uh
there's a buzz word authenticity if I'm
this intentional about connecting with
people and I'm putting forth okay I'm
paying attention to how I listen okay
I'm asking a better question okay I'm
active listening I'm doing this I'm
doing that don't I sort of create an
inauthenticity how is how is all this
not just creating a facade that's
inauthentic and actually creating less
connection so this is anybody who's um
in a relationship has ever come across
the book the five love languages uh my
wife and I had this big aha about these
five love languages uh and it was so one
of her languages is a of service she
receives love through acts of service so
me emptying the dishwasher taking out
the trash tidying up is like just
sending
love and there were some day
particularly busy stressed tired
whatever and I did all of those things
so I did all of the behaviors of them
and it didn't work I was like what the
heck you're not feeling L you don't like
what's going on and then I realized and
we both realized that we had been
participating in the Love Languages but
we forgot to act we forgot the love
part we're doing the behaviors and so
this is why I don't love the concept of
or or just the surface level language of
active listening because the behaviors
without the the true care and interests
and curiosity in a person is just about
useless yeah not totally useless but
just about useless does that get at that
intention piece that you talk about like
the intention is the base of all the
when you talking about and ask powerful
questions intentions at the bottom yeah
we we in the course we we put intention
at the base like I'm going to teach you
how to have a conversation if you don't
get intention
right 100% this is uh when will and I uh
wrote Ask powerful questions the
intention chapter was like a few
paragraphs and then the one of the
editors was like you're teaching all all
this really phenomenal super practical
stuff on how to ask powerful questions
but none of it matters if your intention
is just to get somebody to do something
or manipulation or you centered rather
and so right the structure of the book
that you're referring to is this this
pyramid where intention is on the bottom
so take this for
example I sit down at a bus stop um and
it just out of uh pure illustration sake
for for Pure illustration sake if I sat
down in a bus stop and you gave me the
challenge of building a relationship of
trust with a stranger at that bus
stop and my tool was a question a good
question what brings you Joy so imagine
me rolling up to a bus stop in
Pittsburgh where I live I like hey what
brings you Joy person's like most likely
like switching seats getting on a
different bus yeah moving around Etc now
add intention into that same scenario I
come to the bus stop and I say hey I
know this is kind of odd but I've
recognized we've uh come to this bus
stop and sat on the same bench five
times in a row and taken the same route
and so uh this is a little bit odd but
I'm doing an experiment right now where
I'm trying to ask questions that I
typically don't I'm curious what brings
you
Joy a sentence or two I cannot guarantee
that I'll build a relationship of trust
or that that will go well but I can at
least probably double the chances that a
connection is made with that intention
piece right let let's talk about because
I think as people were listening they
probably felt an theemotion as you
shared that example um
of oh God they're going to they're going
to reject me they're it's going to be
awkward which is like you know like a
cuss word what um you use the phrase
positive risk in some of your work um
what
a is it worth it and why risk rejection
because I think people get stuck right
there right they're right there on the
edge of I'm going to talk to that person
no I'm and I and I and I pull back into
safety and I look I'm pretty good at
this stuff and I watch your workshops
and you'll go out on an abstraction limb
and I'm like oh God are people going to
answer this or they going to be like
what are you talking about it's a
picture of an orange that's not I don't
know how that describes my week just I
look at your toolkit and I'm like I
cannot the amount of like um experiments
that you did to make those I know you
had some people like what is this dude
um how like what is the like is the risk
worth it and can you just flush out the
idea of like talk to people that are
feeling the fear of the risk and like
maybe what would you say to those people
because I think there's a lot of them
that are wrestling through that they're
going to get the content and they're
going to need the
Courage the first thing I would say to
them is I believe you I believe that
you're scared of rejection I believe
that you're worried about what's going
to
happen I don't
believe that the consequences for that
rejection are as great as they are in
your head right
now
so let's see what happens so will and I
met teaching a dialogue facilitation
course and so we would send in in a
college context we would send 30
students in this class we'd set a 30-
minute timer and say you have 30 minutes
go build a relationship of trust with
three strangers I can't teach you this
from a PowerPoint go out outside and do
it go downtown walk around campus find
three strangers build a relationship of
trust and we're going to come back and
debrief what' you do how' it go what was
the impact and so you can imagine a
bunch of college students like that that
emotion is
like extra elevated so what happened is
uh 30 somewhat peeved students left the
classroom and then what came back was 30
like hyper energized uh students and
there was this one student who was
pretty quiet um up into the the class
until that point he actually quieted
everybody down and he was like whoa
whoa I got to tell you I was ticked when
you rolled out this uh this exercise I
did not sign up in this class to leave
the class to go build a relationship
trust with three strangers but I figured
if I had to I might as well go downtown
um and get an errand done so I picked
out a couple things that I
needed and uh picked out a couple things
that I needed and or rewind I did this
exercise myself so I had the same
thinking as the student so I went
downtown to pick out a couple things I
needed because I was like if I'm going
to assign students to this I need to
stay in integrity and so I walked down
picked out a few things and the cashier
had bright colored tattoos all over her
neck I was like ah teach this stuff for
a living I got this hey I'm so uh
Curious what's the story behind your
tattoos and she goes eh I liked the
colors I did not build a relationship of
trust back up absolutely not so student
comes back telling the story now and
he's like okay I get to the the front
and this cashier had bright color
tattoos he went to the same store bright
color tattoos all over her neck and I
just got to the front and I
said I just have to ask how annoying is
it when people ask you about your
tattoos and she goes ah you have no idea
and fact sometimes in the middle of
August I want to be wearing a turtleneck
in fact there's just this guy in here
asking me what's the story behind your
tattoos that's
fantastic and so I think uh for me that
is the power of intention he went in and
his intention was created and made from
within her shoes not within his own he
was not trying to build a relationship
of trust he turned around and said what
must it be like to be you oh you have
really cool tattoos they're but they're
really bright really obvious I bet a lot
of people make comments about that ask
them okay I'm just going to ask you how
annoying is it to and his question was
sourced from what it must be like to be
her and that is the difference between
like things not going well for me and
things potentially going really well
yeah is sourced from empathy as opposed
to like um like self promotion or self
um I to going back to your so you say
like hey I know it's scary that that
emotion is real we're not going to
diminish that um but maybe we can second
guess the severity of what you're you're
forecasting there was and I I don't have
it and perhaps wherever we end up
posting this I can post the notes they
did a study where they asked a bunch of
people to do the same thing have you
seen this and they basically asked them
to estimate how difficult or
uncomfortable it would be to talk to
another person like on the bus on the
subway and they estimate and the people
were like 8 out of 10 uncomfortable n
out of 10 10 out of 10 uncomfortable and
then after they did it they said how
uncomfortable was it and it was like two
out of 10 most of the time and they said
that like
consistently and predictably our
estimation of the difficulty of talking
to another person is drastically higher
and wrong um and so learning to like
second guess those things of like it's
real it feels real second guess it it's
definitely worth it um we're we're we're
pushing up on time so I'm going to pick
you okay okay I'm good I'm good all
right um I uh I'm having fun okay the um
I think a lot of people have this um I
think you would speak to this well uh I
think I saw when you moved
to I don't know if it was where you're
at now or a different city you talked
about this specific issue and I get this
question all the time people get a
little they watch my Instagram they get
they they try out some little tools and
they're magic I mean they really are
magic even if your intention is off you
switch your why question to a how
question all of a sudden the world
starts changing around you it's it's
like Wizardry and so they do it but then
what they find is people start becoming
very talkative with them but they don't
reciprocate those questions and they can
end up in a different version of
loneliness so I was lonely because I
never talked to people now I'm
everybody's therapist because the the
feeling of being
seen is missing in a lot a lot of
people's life they just have they're
like I don't think I've ever felt heard
before so you do that for other people
and all of a sudden everybody's talking
to you and you're like nobody ever asks
about me um how have you wrestled
through that because you're very good at
question asking um on a personal level
and then like how do you navigate
that I heard a friend of mine once say
um a conversation without
self-disclosure is an interrogation yeah
and so that this is the dynamic that
you're pointing to um and an
interrogation uh quite lonely because
you are not actually connected with the
person you're interrogating and so
um what you're the story you're
referring to is when I moved to
Asheville Carolina I lived there for 5
years and my way of settling into the
town and getting to know Asheville cuz I
had no tie whatsoever was showing up to
an entrepreneur Meetup or uh coffee
Meetup or uh random networking thing and
having one-on-one coffe with people over
the course of like two years and I just
kept out of more like reflection I kept
people's business card or whatever
little thing they gave me um as we went
along and so at when I left Asheville I
found this box that had right around
three to 400 different cards meaning
three to 400 individuals that I had a
conversation with and about halfway
through that pile I realized this
Dynamic that you're pointing out which
is I was asking lots of
questions but they left the conversation
feeling like it was a great chat because
they just got to unpack all the stuff
but they have no clue who I am in the
world and so this is what I
did I would stop 10 to 20 minutes into
the conversation and just say ah like
I'm so enjoying this chat and I realize
I've just been like tossing questions um
out to you I'm curious like what are you
curious
about so the Curiosity about curiosity
right I'm curious what questions do you
have toss over here and there you could
see their brain breaks so this is this
what is what I would call a positive
social risk people don't usually do this
in conversation but 200 conversations in
I was like I'm not going to do this 200
more times where we just do this
one-sided thing and so I just started
doing that and it was awesome it like
created the shift leveled the playing
fields and the awkward part was about
the 5-second period where after I asked
that I literally watched their brain
break and go from like they were telling
me about things they already knew
because I was asking about them
to prefrontal Cortex right in the like
the part of your brain that's really
turning
on and they thought and they would
usually look up to the left or the right
and then they toss a question out to me
and so what I did was asked them to ask
me a question I just did it in the form
of a question I just said what questions
did you did you get anybody that was
like uh I don't
know did you get any people that just
didn't have the skill set to ask a
question back no not my reflection
because every kid one of the things I my
little favorite cocktail party fun fact
is kids ages three to five ask 300 to
400 questions per
day adults on average ask six to 12
questions per day and I don't know about
your life but half of those questions
for me are like what should we eat
tonight where are you utility need this
at the store utility not connection y
yeah so they they tended to ask it back
and it took I would imagine some courage
to flip that script I I would imagine I
tried that I remember you talking about
it and I was like I'm going to try it CU
I tend to ask good questions and people
just talk about themselves I'm like oh
my goodness I've been talking all this
time ask you all these questions this is
an interrogation I bet you're curious
what you what you curious about me I
mean that it feels that's a very
vulnerable
suggestion but to the point about
authenticity without some measure of
risk or vulnerability you are being
inauthentic you're just kind of guarding
yourself um and yeah H okay let's let's
shift to work and then we'll be done um
work a lot of what you do is with
companies inside of the workplace
talking about connection and um some
people that will will follow my stuff
it's because they're trying to get
better at this stuff uh in work I'm
curious is there a difference with
connection with that guy in the bus stop
or your you know Thanksgiving table with
your family versus in a work setting
because yes yeah there is but like what
are the rules because the rules seem so
nebulous and unclear but when you break
them I I have a saying that their uh
work is full of implicit rules with
explicit consequences and that's like a
cruelty in the world um so how how do
you how do you suggest that people
navigate um Connection in the workplace
so they they learn these conversation
skills they have a Natural Curiosity but
now they're going to have to filter that
Curiosity based on work how do you
advise differentiating
there I think I probably need to
meditate on this uh for longer but I
think the biggest difference is
anonymity and anonymity relates to
psychological safety it's how safy do I
feel right now in this interaction and
context changes that right so if I ask
what brings you Joy in a dark alley to a
six8 man wearing a trench
coat I don't know I probably feel a
little different than if I'm asking a
colleague that I've worked with and
known for five years and so um the
context of work is for the most part
you're going to see this person again
the bus stop person the risk in some way
I think is actually even though the
procedure risk might be higher I think
the actual risk is lower at the bus stop
person because worst case scenario they
say GH get away from me yeah and you
never see them again at work the worst
case scenario is that you see them the
next day and they have cast some
judgment about who you are based on and
here and here's where it gets important
based
on a genuine curiosity an intent to
connect so they're going to be judging
you based off of a number of really
positive things most likely yeah
now there is like there is a way to
overdo it right I think um if I you know
my opening question there's a scaffold
to connection my opening question to a
colleague um or if I just just wake up
one Monday and I'm like I like I'm sick
of having small talk with my colleagues
like I want to get more meaningful
conversations going I go in and I'm just
like hey I'm sick of the small talk
stuff like can you just tell me
things that you've never told anybody
before and like just unpack your last
therapy session with me right now in
this boardroom that's not going to go
well because the scaffold it's like way
too much that somebody defined trauma
for me as too much too fast too soon so
connection you don't want to traumatize
somebody else by going too much too fast
too soon with your conversation and so
um being curious but put yourselves in
the store clerks with tattoos over the
neck uh Shoe Right Step into their shoe
to say what must life be like for you
okay it's Monday you may or may not want
to be at work right now you're probably
not thinking about the importance of
generating deeper conversations with
colleagues because that's my thing right
now that's what I am caring about you're
just like want to get your stuff done
and so I might ask you a question like
hey I know I usually ask you how your
weekend was I'm curious right now like
what's taking up lots of your brain
space right now yeah way different
scaffold level um and then I I'll say
one other thing that feels like maybe uh
my favorite feature of questions and I
think the most important feature of
questions and that is you can ask any
question to
anyone and for the most part they have
100% choice and autonomy in how they
answer that question and when you are
trying to be a better conversationalist
this is a very thing important thing to
remember to give people their power back
don't think that your question is going
to make them do something specific CU if
you ask me Cole what brings you Joy
actually let's just play this okay Cole
can you give me a level one answer to
this question what brings you Joy um
taking a walk with my dog level one cool
level four answer what is bringing you
Joy uh when my kids are honest with me
about their struggles and they like
trust me with
stuff yeah both are
true and you had full autonomy to pick
which one and they created a different
level of connection so I learned things
in both I connected you with in both and
so I think sometimes we forget like
people choose how they're going to
answer the question and they can choose
to say no so unless you're the CEO and
you're intimidating uh to somebody
because you've set up a culture of
intimidation or just the hierarchy is
intimidating then you need to share do a
little bit more intention sharing to be
like hey I'm not trying to I wouldn't
say this necessarily but the person's
going to be wondering like are you fact
finding so that you can fire me or you
like poaching me for a different
position right so intention getting
about intent when we taught um we're
working on a curriculum for middle
school students right now on how to
connect and the the thing we put
together that was like an adaptation was
that was share and then ask because
people are always wondering why you're
asking so if I can share a little bit
like why I'm asking then you know and I
I would um to some of my neurod
Divergent
students there isn't like your
scaffolding of there are level one level
two level three level four isn't
immediately obvious um because sorting
through a hierarchy um of importance is
actually really difficult for some
brains and so what's help that's
actually very helpful for some people to
be like you do have a choice when
somebody asks you a question um and this
is a little bit how my brain works if
you ask me how are you today I
immediately go to an level four answer I
forget that I can give you a level one
answer and that's going to be okay right
now and that's not BS that's just
appropriate for the context I'm just
seeing you on the sidewalk I don't need
to know that you're stressed about
bankruptcy or that your marriage is in
shambled but everything in my brain
wants to share that like I don't want to
tell you like I'm I'm doing good you
know just uh bring me joy yeah I mean
Sunshine yesterday was really nice like
I feel like I'm um bsing you but I think
it's worth saying that for probably the
majority of the population if it's a
level one context a level one answer
isn't shallow it's appropriate um and to
be to be clear the the important feature
is you you want to choose so let's just
think of every question as a multiple
choice question I there's not very many
conversational like relationship of
trust sort of questions that have only
one answer yeah even closed question
right um did you grow up in Boston well
you know I lived the first six years of
my life in in Ohio and then I moved to
Massachusetts and we lived a little bit
South like there's very very few
questions that have only one answer and
so just for the neurod divergent or not
brain just imagine that each question
and your brain's really quick um and and
a lot of neurod diverent brains are
really quick very quick right and so
just imagine somebody asked you a
question just think of maybe four is too
much just think of like just get two
answers real quick hey how you doing
right now I like that okay how am I
doing literally right now I'm actually
okay it's good to be getting fresh air
yeah and also I'm worried about
bankruptcy we're on a walk I'm just
seeing a neighbor and okay I'm GNA pick
option one your brain can do all of that
in like 08 seconds yeah yeah that's
really great I I think that frees up a
lot of people you you'll see on the
internet a lot of people or students I
talk to like I just want to skip the
small I want to go to the you know
existential deep things and realizing
that context context changes content um
and so I I really want to coin the
phrase Contex deity but I think it just
doesn't come off the tongue very well
you know it's a little tricky a little
tricky though there a little
context so so um I know that we could uh
talk for two hours so maybe one more one
more thing and then um we'll land the
plane
this feels important depth like depth
has nothing to do with the content of
the conversation in my humble opinion it
does not have to do with whether you're
talking about Secrets or philosophy or
the afterlife or if you're talking about
sunshine and teddy bears depth does not
have to do in my opinion with the
content of a conversation it has to do
with the process of the conversation
that's a really
interesting so the process and so when I
think about people wanting to skip small
talk here's what I would invite you
into go deep with the process so be
extra
present extra curious extra caring about
who that person is extra
empathetic even if they're talking about
sunshine and
rainbows because the process is and when
people walk away with they don't think
uh for sure they do think to some level
of like dang like we're just walking our
dogs and we all of a sudden we're
talking about the
afterlife that that's in that is uh
level of intensity but not necessarily
if the process was I bumped into my
neighbor and he's like man it's cold
outside and I and I'm like yeah wouldn't
it be sweet if the afterlife was just
warm that I'm we're talking about that
but the process is totally different
right and so if you're trying to and my
believe that I exist on the planet to
gently eradicate small talk and create
conversation that matters and so for me
I think about how can uh I deepen the
process and not the content and and this
the big learning for me was with my
four-year-old I kept trying to have deep
conversations with my four-year-old he
doesn't give a hoot you know what's deep
to him when Dad gets on his level and
just plays with him play is right now
his language of conversation and so the
content is play but the process is I'm
super present and what I'm communicating
to him is he's the only person that
matters right now I'm not concerned
about anything else going on in Life or
on my phone or anywhere else I'm just
with you and all of that subtext is
communicated through process not through
content yeah is process and presence
synonymous in this
context because a lot of what you're
saying when you say process I see if
you're present to the conversation it
can be qualified as deep is there
something that other than presence that
fits into that process I think so I I I
probably just focus more in presence
there content is what is being said in
the conversation so literally
words process in my the way that I think
about it is literally everything else
other than the
words yeah
so if I want to deepen a
conversation I might turn toward that
person and show them that I'm actually
focused as opposed to what I'm when I'm
walking a dog I usually have one foot
aiming the direction I want to go yeah
yeah because I want to keep going that
way I don't want to square off and and
have this um this chat and
so that said I think the Nuance that you
bump up against of like you know if you
want to just skip past the small talk I
think you can run into some of the same
traps if you just try to deepen process
because if you're walking the dog and
you square off with somebody and you get
hyper presentes even though you're
talking about something flighty that's
also too much so there is a there art
the content still shallow but you're you
don't match it I think of there's um a
lot of people will live their life with
people that are like they want to have a
conversation about it's not sunshine and
rainbows it's um cutting their dog's
nails you know well I cut it and I
bought this powder That was supposed to
stop it from bleeding and then we just
got that carpet and Susan the other day
said that if you get anything on that
carpet you're going to be in TR and you
can feel our minds wandering as I do
this but that is I mean a very genuine
disclosure for that person and so I've
always struggled with how do I show up
to be present to that so I think it's
helpful for me to to remember um the
content doesn't Define depth like
presence and process um have more to do
with depth because that person could
walk away and be man that was really
nice connecting with them today um even
though they talked about that cuz I was
present to it and I listened and I asked
questions CU they chose they said that
that's what I want to talk to you
about this is one of the tools the
Practical tools we teach in the book is
to find something that somebody's
wearing caring sharing or presenting and
ask a question rooted in your Natural
Curiosity the reason we chose that as
one of the main tools to build a quick
relationship of trust is it's something
safe that's in the context when you go
when people kind of uh get stuck trying
to create conversations that matter as
they try to pull things that aren't in
the room they're not there right now and
so if you ask me like hey what's the
story about this ring it's a safe way to
access one of the most important
relationships in my life yep because I'm
here right and so what happens is is a
simple question about a shirt uh that
somebody's wearing or uh what's on the
back of your hat Cole a simple question
like that is a window let's see it oh no
we're no it's a Buy's hat I this is not
sponsored by bies I've never been to a
bies but my friend bought me the hat and
I'm I mean I could be bought by anybody
if they just buy me clothes because I
hate so watch this right some some of
your folks would be saying well we're
just having a Sur surface level
conversation about bies right now watch
this the magic of a second
question you mentioned uh like friend
got you that hat I'm curious uh how
how'd you meet that friend oh gosh yeah
there's a whole Rabbit Hole there Mike
was yeah yeah I we would
just remembering that often times that
surface level small talk with just the
magic of a second question can safely go
to a conversation that matters to you or
to them or hopefully both and we cover
that stuff in in the conversation course
because what I find is a lot of people
are just they're in those dual
monologues where they're just sharing
like stories with the intent to connect
they really are trying to connect
through like stories but you never quite
get past that surface because you're
just ping ponging
stories well dude we could do this uh
for a couple hours
probably um this has been delightful um
guys if you're watching this go check
out Chad's stuff if you run a company um
if you need somebody to come in work
with your teams there there really is
nobody nobody better you can go to his
website see all the logos um see all the
testimonies they're genuine um and uh
above all credentials uh Chad has been a
really kind friend to me uh and uh I
think he's doing a lot of good in the
world so Chad thanks for being here
thanks for carving out the time and um I
hope the rest of your day is full of
lovely connections with your family and
whoever you got next and I'm going to uh
close by holding up a mirr and sending
all that affirmation right back to you
thanks man cheers